sehr geehrte damen und herren ich
begrüße sie herzlich zur pressekonferenz
bilanz pressekonferenz über die einsätze
des bundesheers im jahr 2020 mit
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
mit dem generalstabschef general robert
brieger und dem leiter der einsatz
sektion general karl schmidseder und ich
darf die frau bundesministerin ersuchen
zu beginnen
general leutnant sehr geehrte damen und
herren medienvertreter das vergangene
jahr das hätte unser heer so gefordert
wie es schon lange nicht mehr der fall
war und das kurz andauernde heurige jahr
das scheint in einer ähnlichen taktung
weiter zu gehen nachdem ultima ratio
prinzip wird das heißt wenn andere nicht
mehr können oder noch nicht können dann
ist unser bundesheer da wenn es
gebraucht wird es helfen kann und das
ist mir ganz wichtig zu betonen wenn
sonst niemand mehr kann
das macht das wesen des bundesheeres aus
und ist gesetzlich aus auch so
festgehalten das heißt unser heer war
und ist im rahmen der korona pandemie
immer in assistenz tätig und das möchte
ich an dieser stelle noch einmal betonen
war immer da wenn es gebraucht wurde nun
zur beeindruckenden bilanz im
vergangenen jahr wurde erstmals in der
geschichte der zweiten republik im
frühling die milizsoldaten in einer teil
mobilmachung einberufen
das war keine leichte entscheidung die
wir gemeinsam getroffen haben aber es
war eine richtige und auch der
präsenzdienst von circa 2.300
präsenzdienern musste als unterstützung
und zur gewährleistung
um der durchhaltefähigkeit der
einsatzbereitschaft des bundesheeres
verlängert werden
unsere eingesetzten soldatinnen soldaten
und zivilbediensteten helfen im kampf
gegen kuwait 19 reichte bei
grenzkontrollen beim contact tracing bei
der durchführung und unterstützung der
flächendeckenden testungen hier wurde am
höhepunkt der testung einem großaufgebot
von über 5.400 bediensteten im gesamten
bundesgebiet eingesetzt und das freut
mich als ressortchefin ganz besonders
über 95 prozent der getesteten waren mit
der arbeit unserer soldatinnen soldaten
und zivilbediensteten zufrieden das ist
ein überwältigendes zeugnis für die
großartige arbeit unseres bundesheeres
über fünf millionen test kits sind
bundesweit ausgeliefert worden durch uns
in spitzenzeiten waren bis zu 8000 600
soldatinnen soldaten und
zivilbedienstete zur auftragserfüllung
im in- und im ausland im einsatz
und dann hatten wir auch noch mit der
bevorratung zu tun es wurden fünf
strategische cupid 19 notlager errichtet
die insbesondere dazu dienen sollen
engpässe oder bedarfsspitzen für einen
bestimmten zeitraum auszugleichen und
somit dann auch den temporären ausfall
von etablierten beschaffungswege
bestmöglich entgegenzuwirken und
zusätzliche war es noch notwendig die
österreichische bevölkerung mit
assistenz einsätzen zur bewältigung von
naturkatastrophen zu unterstützen
insbesondere in vorarlberg kärnten
niederösterreich burgenland steiermark
nord und osttirol im rahmen dieser
einsätze wurden bäche und flüsse von
verklausungen befreit unwetter schäden
beseitigt schäden an zivilen
brückenkonstruktionen für
dächer von der schneelast befreit und
einsatzkräfte bei der brandbekämpfung
aus der luft unterstützt in summe waren
es 17 assistenzleistungen mit unseren
hubschraubern zum schutz der bevölkerung
dabei wurden 169 flugstunden geflogen
und über 800.000 liter löschwasser
abgeworfen um hier nur ein beispiel zu
nennen
die zuständige - dienste haben
großartige arbeit geleistet im jahr 2020
im gesamten bundesgebiet bei 1265
einsätzen wurden rund 26 tonnen
kriegsmaterial einzeln geborgen
untersucht beurteilt abtransportiert und
vernichtet
ja und gerade im 60 jährigen
jubiläumsjahr der auslandseinsätze ist
auch das engagement in internationalen
organisationen für österreich ein sehr
wichtiges element unserer aktiven
neutralitätspolitik sie wissen unser
heer beteiligt sich seit dem jahr 1960
kontinuierlich an internationalen
friedenseinsätzen und leistet damit hat
bis dato über 100 internationalen
einsatz noch aktiv teilgenommen es
leistet damit im kontext des
österreichischen engagements zur
internationalen friedenssicherung einen
maßgeblichen weiterer gutach aktuell
stehen rund 1000 österreichische
soldatinnen und soldaten in 16 missionen
weltweit im einsatz
wenn wir dann den zweiten november zum
denken an die furchtbare nach des
terroranschlags auch da ist unser
bundesheer aktiv geworden wir haben
sofort die bewachung von weiteren
objekten übernommen wie botschaften
internationalen organisationen und auch
das jagt kommando in einsatzbereitschaft
gesetzt sie sehen unser bundesheer ist
in einer unglaublichen intensität
gefordert und ich oder wir sind stolz
sagen zu können
auf unser heer ist verlass dass das so
ist das haben hat auch die bevölkerung
unserer bevölkerung gesehen und das bild
des österreichischen bundesheeres hat
sich erwiesenermaßen bei sehr vielen
menschen zum positiven entwickelt der
eine oder andere hatte der vergangenheit
in unserem land nur sehr wenige
berührungspunkte mit dem bundesheer im
vergangenen jahr war und das wird auch
so bleiben heuer ist das zweifelsohne
anders wir sind heuer sichtbarer denn je
all dies wäre nicht möglich gewesen ohne
die soldatinnen und soldaten aller
dienstgrade sowie zivilbediensteten
meines ressorts
ich möchte an dieser stelle danke sagen
danke für euren einsatz für ihr
engagement für euren dienst für
österreich dankeschön nicht auf den
herrn karl suchen
sehr geehrte frau bundesminister
geschätzte damen und herren die frau
bundesminister hat es erwähnt der krone
einsatz der das jahr 2020 wesentlich
beherrscht hat hat in den augen der
bevölkerung für das bundesheer sozusagen
einen imageschub erbracht den ich sehr
begrüße und für den ich auch sehr
dankbar bin weil es gelegenheit wahr die
leistungen der soldatinnen und soldaten
einer breiten öffentlichkeit sichtbar zu
machen und zwar in einem
gesamtstaatlichen kontext in kooperation
mit dem gesundheitsministerium mit dem
innenministerium mit dem roten kreuz und
mit anderen organisationen die insgesamt
bei der bewältigung dieser krise
aufgaben übernehmen müssen
für mich als generalstabschef steht der
einsatz stets im vordergrund
und sie ist hier prioritär bei einer
derartigen pandemie natürlich für den
schutz der bevölkerung
sozusagen für alle soldatinnen und
soldaten auch die motivation hier tätig
zu werden und aktiv mitzuhelfen
wir haben daneben aber auch das jahr
2020 genutzt um im auftrag der frau
bundesminister überlegungen anzustellen
über die zukunft des österreichischen
bundesheeres
ich habe im sommer vergangenen jahres
den auftrag erhalten eine ergebnisoffene
und breit angelegte beurteilung
anzustellen hinsichtlich der künftigen
ausprägung und organisation der
streitkräfte und wir haben das
eingeleitet wie das üblich ist bei einer
solchen beurteilung mit der erstellung
eines risiko bildes das die künftigen
bedrohungen und risken natürlich auch in
einem internationalen kontext
entsprechend beleuchtet wir haben aus
diesem risikobild
verteidigungspolitische ableitungen
getätigt und haben nunmehr kurz vor dem
jahreswechsel daraus profil varianten
für das künftige österreichische
bundesheer entwickelt die wir auch erst
kürzlich davor bundesminister vorstellen
durften
das heißt es ist die aufgabe des
generalstabes natürlich neben der
bewältigung laufen der einsätze auch
zukunftsweisende überlegungen über das
bundesheer insgesamt anzustellen und es
ist hierbei natürlich zu erwähnen dass
wir ungeachtet unseres status als
immerwährend neutraler staat hier in
einem internationalen kontext denken
müssen bedrohungen hybrider natur so wie
sie heute und in zukunft aktuell sind
lassen sich rein national kaum noch
bewältigen und auch innerhalb österreich
sind das gesamtstaatliche aufgaben die
hier dann an uns heran stehen
diese breite perspektive war sozusagen
planungsleiter und für unsere
überlegungen und ich gehe davon aus dass
auch im zusammenhang mit den
budgeterhöhungen für die ich sehr
dankbar bin uns die gelegenheit gegeben
wird hier einen vernünftigen ausbau eine
vernünftige weiterentwicklung des
bundesheeres einzuleiten wir haben wie
gesagt das jahr 2020 für erste
bearbeitungen genutzt und wir werden das
erste halbjahr 2021 dazu nutzen hier
entsprechende weitere überlegungen
anzustellen und organisatorische
ableitungen zu treffen die uns in die
lage versetzen sollen die streitkräfte
künftig den aktiv stand die miliz die
gesamtheit der organisation der
waffengattung am fit zu machen für die
zukunft mit der perspektive
das österreichische bundesheer soll bis
zum jahr 2030 in der lage sein die dann
erwartbaren bedrohungen und risken zum
schutz der österreichischen bevölkerung
entsprechend zu beantworten
vielen dank da geschönt bitte eher
gelangweilt den speziellen einsatz
aufgaben des jahres 2020 einsetzen
können mitunter anstrengend sein
deswegen wir sicher und strengen in fünf
minuten zeige ich ihnen jetzt fünf
folien mit gesamt 24 bildern
das schöne daran ist sie sehen nur
bilder und keinen text wir starten mit
einer aufgabe die für uns letztes jahr
um diese zeit auch in dieser zeit noch
keine priorität hatte der aber plötzlich
sehr wichtig ist sie wissen die
hauptaufgabe ist und bleibt die
militärische landesverteidigung aber im
jahr 2020 hatte plötzlich die assistenz
zur katastrophenhilfe das sperrige
begriff den wir hierfür verwenden ist
die gesundheitsbehörde assistenzleistung
priorität und deswegen diese bilder am
anfang sehen in der mitte die massen
festungen
ich glaube das sieht man jetzt nicht
aber sie können es am bild erkennen in
der mitte
den maßen festungen dann sehen sie links
oben die einreisekontrollen die
gesundheitsbehörden 1 30 kontrollen wie
diesen berühmten fiebermesser dasselbe
auch rechts oben links unten die kontext
razer eine aufgabe mit der vor einem
jahr nicht viel anfangen konnte
plötzlich sah man mittendrin für die
bezirkshauptmannschaften das contact
racing zu machen
die frau bundesministerin im bild in der
mitte unten übergibt entsprechende
masken an das bildungsministerium wir
haben sehr viele logistische aufgaben
wahrgenommen
rechts unten sehen sie die desinfektions
aufgabe hier das bild vom
niederösterreichischen landtag wir haben
auch kindergärten desinfiziert
polizeidienststellen desinfiziert etc
und das bild auf der rechten seite in
der mitte das ist ein pflegeheim in der
steiermark wo einfach die die zahlen
explodiert sind und das pflegepersonal
betroffen war der musste aber
einspringen und das ist ein klassiker
für assistenz zur katastrophenhilfe nach
dem motto ultima ratio
zuerst hinein und nach 14 tagen übergibt
man die aufgabe wieder das führt mich
jetzt zur zweiten folie zur
sicherheitspolizeilichen assistenz ist
im prinzip nichts neues an der grenze
sehen rechts unten das bild an der an
der grenze haben wir nach wie vor etwa
1000 soldatinnen soldaten burgenland
steiermark und kärnten aber im jahr 20
kam auch viel dazu und zwar in einer
stärkeren form als wir erwarten konnten
nämlich aufgrund des 2 november kommt
der anstatt dieses anschlages im ersten
bezirk wo wir den objektschutz im
verstärkt haben
die zusammenarbeit mit der polizei und
der sicherheitspolizeilichen
assistenzeinsatz fuß der auf einem
antrag des innenministeriums ist
wirklich ausgezeichnet kommen wir zur
dritten aufgabe nämlich unserem auslands
engagement die klassischen bilder sehen
sie oben
bekannte uno einsätze hier eine
impression vom libanon rechts unten
unser engagement im kosovo wir haben
seit kurzem wieder schon seit jahren den
kommandanten in bosnien übernommen wir
haben den stellvertretenden kommandanten
der kfor im kosovo rechts oben die
battlegroups
aber wir sind nach wie vor engagiert
engagiert in den beutel groups
europäischen union wir hatten letztes
jahr die logistische führung in einer
deutsch geführten battle group und jetzt
kommen zwei bilder die wir so nicht
erwarten konnten ganz links sehen sie
unsere unterstützung bei heim hohler
flügen der austrian airlines wo wir mit
qualifiziertem personal unterstützt
haben einen flug habe auch aus
frankreich gemacht von sozusagen
gestrandeten die wir mit der hercules
nach österreich zurückgebracht haben und
in der mitte unten ich muss ehrlich
sagen ich hätte nie daran gedacht wird
dass wir das lowak ein auslandseinsatz
haben
das sind die das ist die unterstützung
der slowakischen autoritäten bei der
testung das norwegischen bevölkerung
bitte zum nächsten bild das sind
unterstützungsleistungen die wir dann
machen wenn wir die ressourcen haben
wenn es an mehrwert hat für die
ausbildung wenn es auch um wer
politische effekte geht und ich darf
betonen die werden auch finanziell
refundiert also die werden nach einem
gewissen kostensatz bezahlt ob das jetzt
märkte sind wie spar oder andere große
österreichische unternehmen oder die
produktion von desinfektionsmittel das
ist das bild in der mitte oben oder aber
eine unterstützung von farma betrieben
oder die post die ja auch ein
riesenproblem in der nähe von wien in
hagenbrunn hatte oder rechts das bild
die überprüfung von masken auch für
andere einsatzorganisationen ich kann
zum letzten was haben wir sonst noch
gemacht das darf man nicht
vernachlässigen es gibt auch
assistenzeinsätze zur katastrophenhilfe
die person nichts mit kurve zu tun haben
speziell in den letzten wochen in der
schönen in osttirol und in kärnten das
bild links oben symbolisiert das dann
natürlich die unterstützung bei der
waldbrandbekämpfung auch mit
hubschraubern
in der mitte die frau bundesministerin
hatte angesprochen noch immer aufgaben
des entminungsdienstes und rechts
natürlich die aktive luftraumüberwachung
wo wir natürlich bei entsprechenden
anlass fällen auch die identifikation
machen also insgesamt ein sehr
ereignisreiches jahr
und die dürfen anschließend die gruppe
macht das ganz hervorragend unsere
soldatinnen soldaten an der basis
braucht man wirklich super job und ich
freue mich sehr dass die bevölkerung
stolz ist dankeschön
jetzt sind dank ich versuche nun um ihre
fragen und suchen sie zu warten bis es
mikrofon und riss mit der kappacher
zwei fragen die vom minister zuerst und
auch an den kanal präger dass ich mich
schon länger frage ist diese teil
mobilisierung die sie als gut und
richtig wenn auch eine schwierige
entscheidung bezeichnet haben warum war
die notwendigen im frühjahr und im
herbst nicht nur im herbst waren ja
immer alle wissen und auch jetzt wieder
gesehen haben viel mehr aufgaben für das
bundesheer zu erledigen es gab die maßen
leistungen nicht nur über die
grenzsicherung und und diese dinge war
das vielleicht doch überzogen wenn man
sie jetzt im nachhinein betrachtet hat
man da was ausprobieren wollen dass er
auch die frage eine general präger war
das jahr 2020 für das heer auch so eine
gelegenheit eine möglichkeit die
einsatzfähigkeit des jahres einmal zum
in der realität zu testen
das ist die eine frage an die andere
frage ist was ist ein vernünftiger
vernünftiger ausbau und
weiterentwicklung des heeres jetzt auch
auf basis dieses image das dem mann
thema und bekommen hat das bundesheer in
welche richtung geht das und gehen sie
davon aus dass das jetzt auch
mittelfristig abgesichert passieren kann
dass man budget zu sagen hat die man
nicht jedes jahr wieder mühsam erkämpfen
muss und und und erringen muss
haben sie da es als ministerin in der
regierung diesen rückhalt schon zugesagt
bekommen weil das her hat sicherheits
tatsächlich für alle sichtbar bewährt
ich darf mit der ersten frage beginnen
und damit auch mit dem beginn der
pandemie als sehr vieles noch nicht
absehbar war und insbesondere die von
jahren general leutnant so einprägsamen
bildern dargestellten einsätze noch
nicht absehbar waren
der grund der notwendigkeit die
notwendigkeit der teil mobilisierung der
miliz lag insbesondere daran die
durchhaltefähigkeit auch sicher zu
stellen weil diese zahlreichen
einsätze die eben notwendig geworden
sind seien es jetzt assistenzeinsätze
oder auch die dargestellten
unterstützungsleistungen sind ja welche
die 24/7 auch zu leisten sind wenn man
in der geschichte zurückgeht das
durchaus einmal schon die notwendigkeit
vielleicht auch gegeben
diese aufbietung der militzer
vorzunehmen
daher habe ich auch angesprochen wir
haben uns gemeinsam diese entscheidung
nicht leicht gemacht rückblickend sehen
wir dass sie notwendig war so wie jeder
militärische einsatz ist aber auch in
diesem fall sehr vieles zutage getreten
dass wir positiv verändern müssen wenn
sie nur daran denken was
sozialrechtliche gleich stellungen auch
beim einsatz oder milizsoldaten
anbelangt wenn ich nur an die bezahlung
denke und wenn ich auch daran denke was
an notwendigkeiten der ausstattung auch
im miliz bereich notwendig ist beginnend
von der mobilität wo wir ja die ersten
schritte schon gesetzt haben über auch
die ausstattung der soldaten an sich das
führt mich dann auch schon zu ihrer
zweiten frage nämlich der budgetären
wenn wir das jahr anschauen und das
ansehen dass das bundesheer gewonnen hat
und wenn wir dann zurück blicken dass
das österreichische bundesheer sehr oft
nur unter den budgetären mangel
diskutiert werden ist aber nicht an der
leistung die erbracht wird er dann ist
es schon so dass wir erstmalig und
historisch einen zweimaligen budget
anstieg im regel budget im verzeichnen
können
unter dass wir auch verzeichnen können
sondern invest pakete die fixiert worden
sind gerade in den entscheidenden
bereichen die sich dann auch aus dem
risiko bild ergeben um mir nur dass
miliz paket an erster stelle zu nennen
das sanitäts paket das auszugestalten
ist die investitionen im bereich auch
der abc abwehr
die investitionen die notwendig sind in
zusammenhang mit dem terror paket die
budgetäre ausgestaltung des bundesheeres
ist jetzt auf die richtige schiene
gebracht worden und genauso werden wir
auch weiter arbeiten und da hilft
natürlich auch das ansehen und die
anerkennung die die österreichische
bevölkerung unser zuteil werden lässt
und dass wir so wie noch niemals zuvor
unter beweis stellen konnten dass wir
tatsächlich auch jede anforderung die
gekommen ist erfüllen konnten
bis zu einer der wohl vor einem jahr
überhaupt nicht vorstellbar war
das wäre ein pflegeheim vollständig für
einen begrenzten zeitraum auch
übernehmen
das ist darum gehen früher eine teil
mobilisierung im herbst war überhaupt
keine rede mehr davon das würde sogar
glaube ich dezidiert ausgeschlossen dass
es noch einmal zu einer mobilisierung
kommt das würde mich einfach
interessieren weil hat man daraus
gelernt dass es eigentlich nicht
notwendig ist dass man mit dem
präsidenten kräften auch auskommt ich
musste noch einmal eines betonen zu
diesem zeitpunkt wo so viele sind
zusammenhang mit der pandemie nicht
absehbar wann diese beiden historischen
maßnahmen notwendig da teil aufbietung
der miliz vorangeschritten war eine
verlängerungen aufschub präsenzdienst
für in etwa 2300 grundwehrdiener und
daran angeschlossen die aufbietung der
miliz zum damaligen zeitpunkt konnte
niemand voraussehen welche
assistenzeinsätze
unterstützungsleistungen eben notwendig
werden und daher war dieser schritt ein
richtiger ich sage aber noch einmal ein
richtiger den wir uns sicher nicht
leichter gemacht haben
wir müssen als strategische reserve zu
jedem zeitpunkt sicher stellen können
alle anforderungen zu erfüllen und das
war insbesondere zu beginn
pandemie notwendig und es ist ja nicht
ausgeschlossen dass das ein weiteres mal
auch der fall sein wird was man auch
gesehen hat bei dieser ausbildung die
wichtigkeit der miliz an sich wenn sie
die bilder der flächendeckenden tests
insbesondere auch in wien gesehen haben
das war dann auch eine erstmalige
historisch eine erstmalige
verantwortlichkeit die milizsoldaten bei
diesen testungen zu tragen hatten in der
stadtteile sind sie federführend von dem
milizsoldaten eben durchgeführt worden
und die erkenntnisse die wir aus dieser
ersten aufbietung der miliz gewinnen
konnten werden auch zu einer erfüllung
eines weiteren punktes im
regierungsprogramm führen der heißt er
den verfassungsmäßigen zustand in
zusammenhang mit dem milizsystem im
österreichischen bundesheer haben wieder
herzustellen
durchaus mit den massen leistungen ein
sehr hohes personal aufkommen des
bundesheeres gefragt das war aber doch
kurzfristiger und daher absehbar als in
dieser ersten phase die die frau
bundesminister skizziert hat die zu
dieser teil aufbieten geführt hat der
teil aufbietung ist er ein aufschub der
entlassung aus dem präsenzdienst für
mehrere monate
der präsenzdiener vorausgegangen und wir
haben mit beiden maßnahmen eine
nachhaltige abdeckung aller
anforderungen sicherstellen können
natürlich ist es für für den generalstab
und für die verantwortlichen auch ein
wichtiger erfahrungsgewinn also insofern
haben sie schon recht mit ihrer frage
wir haben diese teil auf beetle genutzt
um erstmals erfahrungen hinsichtlich
zeitbedarf organisations bedarf
natürlich auch notwendigkeit von
freistellungen von entsprechenden
mangelberufen zu gewinnen und sind
bei dieser erfahrungen natürlich jetzt
in das system einzuspeisen
damit wir künftig davon ausgehen können
dass es noch besser und konsistenter
funktioniert zur frage der
weiterentwicklung der streitkräfte was
planungsleiter und ist für unsere
überlegungen ist die sogenannte hybride
bedrohung das heißt ein bedrohungs
muster das sich vom früheren bedrohungs
muster konventioneller art im kalten
krieg wesentlich unterscheidet weil es
viel breiter ist und weil es von
einflussnahme im subkutanen bereich bis
hin zur terroranschlägen bis hinauf zum
einsatz konventioneller mittel
eigentlich eine unglaublich breite
palette von risk und bedrohungen umfasst
das bedeutet dass die sogenannte
operation für das österreichische
bundesheer eine hauptaufgabe in der
bewältigung solcher hybrider bedrohungs
muster bleiben wird und künftig sein
wird das heißt schutz kritischer
infrastruktur schutz von transfair star
von transversale also von bewegungs
linien strategischer natur sowie das
donautal oder auch die die bei einer
verbindung in den süden und darüber
hinaus reaktionsfähigkeit eine art der
einsatzführung die wie gesagt mit der
rein konventionellen verteidigung des
kalten krieges nichts zu tun hat aber an
den soldaten und an die organisation
höchste anforderungen stellt das bleibt
für uns planungsleiter und natürlich
gibt es verschiedene möglichkeiten der
antwort die auch einen verschiedenen
ressourcenbedarf und veränderungsbedarf
beinhalten aber über konkrete
entscheidungen hierzu zu berichten wird
thema einer späteren pressekonferenz
sein mit hervester nächste
[Musik]
frisieren ein bisschen die frage welche
lehren ziehen sie aus dem vergangenen
jahr sei das budget aber wo sie
offensichtlich zufrieden sind
aber was kommt auf das bundesheer jetzt
mal die nächsten monate noch abgesehen
auf das bundesheer zu bis zum jahresende
vielleicht in der zweiten jahreshälfte
und welche lehren sind sie sozusagen
mittelfristig daraus gibt es eine
umstrukturierung in irgendeiner form
dann also was hat man gelernt aus diesem
jahr
ich darf da vielleicht beim herrn
generalstabchef anschließen
das risikobild das jetzt neu von unseren
experten dargestellt worden ist
unterscheidet sich wenn wir ein jahr
zurückgehen doch sehr von dem das im
zuge der sicherheitspolitischen
jahresvorschau voriges jahr dargestellt
worden ist der ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit einer pandemie und
das war mitte jänner des vergangenen
jahres mit einer wahrscheinlichkeit von
50 prozent angegeben worden und in
wahrheit sind wir jetzt über ein jahr
mitten drinnen das heißt die lehre die
wir zum einen daraus ziehen ist risiko
bilder sowie das ja auch europaweit und
weltweit passiert zu aktualisieren und
aus diesen dann die entsprechenden
ableitungen zu treffen und darauf
aufbauend dann auch die streitkräfte
profil varianten zu diskutieren das ist
ein prozess in dem wir mitten drinnen
sind welche lehren haben wir daraus
gezogen
das sind wohl mehrere wir haben gesehen
und unter beweis gestellt oder stellen
müssen dass wir tatsächlich die
strategische reserve der republik sind
dass es notwendig ist dass wir uns um
die grundwehrdiener kümmern dies auf
eine spezielle art und weise da wir ja
mitten in den geburts schwachen
jahrgängen auch an
lang sind die grundwehrdiener sind die
basis für die die kadersoldaten dass
unsere berufssoldaten und auch unser
militzer system daher haben wir mit
diesem jahr begonnen auch die
tauglichkeitskriterien zu verändern um
mir die entsprechende mannstärke auch
sicherzustellen stellen zu können nach
denen neben dann das berufs jahr unter
das milizsystem aufbaut
wir haben gesehen dass auch
unterstützungsleistungen in
verschiedensten bereichen immer
wichtiger werden dass wir diese auch
rechtlich genau beleuchten müssen wie
von generalleutnant angesprochen sind
diese dann zu genehmigen und auch zu
bezahlen wenn er kein erkenntnisgewinn
zum beispiel daraus eben zu erzielen ist
das was die die erkenntnis ist ist das
durchhaltefähigkeit auch nur in einem
zusammenwirken eines bundesheeres
notwendig ist das heißt die bedeutung
der miliz die ich vorhin schon
angesprochen hat es insbesondere auch
auf die man stärken aber auch auf die
fähigkeiten dem ist besondere priorität
zu geben wir haben unter beweis gestellt
dass wir die strategische reserve der
republik sind wir haben unter beweis
stellen müssen dass es einsätze gibt die
vor einem jahr überhaupt noch nicht
vorstellbar gewesen wären und wenn wir
dieses jahr jetzt
betrachten dieses kurze jahr betrachten
dann wird sich das auch nicht besonders
ändern wir haben uns strategisch nach
dem militärischen grundsätzen darauf
vorzubereiten und bereit zu stehen und
ich bin überzeugt davon dass wir das
auch bewältigen werden
da gibt es weitere fragen wenn es keine
weiteren fragen gibt und sage ich
herzlichen dank für kommen und
behinderte pressekonferenz